is the president running for reelection
the president as you know has been asked
that question many times and he has
answered it uh his answer has been
pretty simple which is yes he's running
for reelection i can't say more than
that
white house responding to the fierce
rumor mill surrounding president biden's
2024 prospects after the new york times
published a brutal report that members
of his own party see him as an anchor
that should be cut loose the times
interviewing more than 50 democratic
officials and some are doubting the
president's ability to rescue the party
from a potential midterm blowout citing
his age and other issues a current dnc
member summing it up this way quote to
say our country was on the right track
would flagrantly depart from reality
biden should announce his attempt not to
seek re-election in 24 right after the
midterms oh that's my prediction date
right jesse oh it is all right president
biden getting no mercy from younger
members of his party listen to what
alexandria ocasio-cortez has to say
about a second term he is saying he's
going to run again in 2024 will you
support him if the president has a
vision and that's something certainly
we're all willing to entertain and
examine when the time comes
that's not a yes
yeah you know i think we should
endorse when we get to it
democrats set on dumping president biden
can point to a laundry list of reasons
national gas prices have skyrocketed to
over five dollars a gallon americans are
feeling the impact of inflation hitting
on everything from shelter to medical
care and some of the media fear it's
just too late for things to turn around
you've seen him change his tone a little
bit when talking about inflation because
in the beginning a lot of democrats are
saying hey look the economy it's doing
great it's the best in you know record
number of years and people weren't
feeling that people were saying why are
you telling me it's good when all these
prices are going up so you are starting
to see democrats shift the messaging a
little bit to talk more about and have
that empathy but whether that is a
little too late we're still a couple
months away but it could be a little too
late for a lot of these people who are
saying
we need help now all right you can see
how this is going to go jesse yeah the
new york times writes a piece like this
and there will be 10 more pieces like
that in other media before next sunday
so this story is going to last for a
while the difference is it's not
republicans saying biden shouldn't run
again now the calls are coming from
inside the house well i don't know why
it took so long for democrats to figure
out joe couldn't cut it i mean but you
have afghanistan gas prices inflation he
missed two surges omicron and delta
didn't get billed back better passed i
mean i know the guy couldn't cut it when
he tripped up the steps three times and
now the democrats according to the times
you're saying oh we're so concerned
about by not being able to rescue the
democrats how about being able to rescue
the country notice they're so concerned
about their hold on power not how well
the country's doing and it's pretty lame
for the democrats to point their fingers
at joe biden this is everything the
democrats campaigned on they campaigned
on getting rid of fossil fuels they
campaigned on opening up the border this
is all the democrats doing to turn
around and point the finger at joe
that's like joe putting the finger at
putin that's what they campaigned on and
if they hadn't look what they would have
done with six trillion dollars more if
they had had their way they would have
taken away our rifles think about how
worse it could have gotten
right now the democrats are lucky and
aoc is coming out it reminds me of the
girl at prom you know you ask a girl the
problem and she goes yeah
well
um you know he's got a nice personality
um i'm more focused on finals right now
she's waiting for a better offer right
right you know when it gets closer to
prom maybe we'll take a look at it but
notice her language she goes we'll take
a look at it she's speaking for the
entire left wing of the party we will
take a look at it and i think what's
going to happen the democrats are going
to get shredded in the midterms and aoc
is going to come in with a knife and
just stab him right there and he's done
and if he does try to run for reelection
they're going to primary the guy and you
know what happens when the incumbent
gets primary look what happened to
carter much weakened and then even bush
41 had the third party action and that's
just not good and the it's funny that
the times comes out and does this
because they didn't want joe to begin
with remember they wanted a woman they
endorsed well they both
so now they're saying yeah yeah let's
get rid of the guy but you know i i'm
i'm relishing how this is going to play
out aoc mate might not just be talking
about the left-wing jessica but also
young people so i saw some numbers today
showing that he's just absolutely
bleeding support
from young people what are you hearing
young people gen z's more than
millennials don't like politics at all
they just don't like the two-party
system they have issues that they care
about and then they're going to look for
people that represent them well on those
issues which is why when they do vote
they tend to vote liberal because they
believe climate change is man-made and
they want criminal justice reform et
cetera
she's definitely speaking about a real
problem but aoc does this constantly and
she falls in line and she was one of the
strongest bernie sanders surrogates she
fell in line and then became a huge
champion for president biden on the
campaign trail i would not say the same
thing about rashida talib and alan omar
but aoc is the most politically savvy i
would say of the squad and she knows
that if she wants the right committee
assignments if she wants to make sure
that she stays in prime time that she's
going to have to fall in line there but
what's going on is there are progressive
qualms with what he's doing but it's the
moderates that i think are actually more
of an issue the people who really wanted
joe biden to be the choice during the
primary and then once he got into power
because they're having to answer
questions about rhetoric that you know
doesn't speak for them or their
districts you know people are still
bringing up what about defund the police
they're dealing with inflation they want
to talk about you know how the everyday
guy is feeling about the gas prices and
what's going on at the grocery store and
feels like the party is off track with
that and that biden has tacked too far
to the left and then the left doesn't
feel like he's gone far enough
um so he's getting it from both sides
but
all individuals if he loses more support
from the left judge his numbers could go
even lower because that's actually
helping bolster him right now and the
numbers are pretty low just want to play
one's piece of sound because there's a
producer on our show who loves it
it happened today is president biden on
whether he's going to saudi arabia
love this
or whether to go to saudi arabia
no not yet what would be
holding up the decision this morning it
happens to be a larger meeting taking
place in saudi arabia that's the reason
i'm going and it has to do with national
security for them for israelis i have a
program anyway it has to do with much
larger issues than having to do with the
energy is he going is he not going just
well i don't have anything to announce
for you today
i feel a little sorry for her because
when there's when you can't announce a
meeting yet then you're dancing around
but
the fact that he's even going to saudi
arabia and
willing to
basically go against what he said in the
campaign
but not willing to open up more here in
america is pretty stunning to people
none of what joe biden does makes any
sense and the the problem is that with
joe biden
in the the democrat party what you've
got is a party that is ideologically so
connected it's almost like a cult okay
the democrats don't vote for republicans
basically under any circumstances that i
know of republicans will vote for a
democrat they'll criticize donald trump
the month after he gets in the democrats
don't criticize joe biden that's why
there are all these whispers that
they're talking about but the the
concern is this in spite of the economy
and inflation and everything else in the
blame game and the american public sees
through it they don't buy into the blame
game all the american public wants to
know joe what are you going to do about
this how are you going to change this
how are you going to make my life better
how are you going to make my life better
and all this guy can talk about is green
energy buying lithium batteries from
china opening up the uh a pipeline for
russia so we can buy gas from russia and
then you know making sure that he shuts
down our pipeline when we can't even
afford to go to work some people they
can't afford to buy food they can't
afford to buy groceries it's just a mess
here and joe biden would have a better
shot at it if he at least didn't depend
on other countries the opec country for
oil russia opening up their pipeline
china lithium batteries everything he
does puts america last so i don't care
if they whisper or they don't whisper
it's over for joe after the midfield
it's interesting that a lot of the
people that democrats suggest could be
their nominee in 2024 in these whisper
campaigns are all people that joe biden
beat in the primary so it's like where
where is their new blood
they are there is no new blood that's a
problem is they don't have a bench to
turn to they certainly don't have a vice
president to turn to in this particular
context now i would say that who saw
donald trump coming in 2014 either so
the the the context of where we are
right now doesn't necessarily mean
that's entire crop but there isn't much
on the bench no doubt
this is this is an order going out from
on high from headquarters when the new
york times cites 50 mostly anonymous
democratic operatives almost all of
which say joe's got to go that's a
warning shot and they know they can't
say it openly before the midterms you
can't make them a lame duck right away
there's no sense in doing so this is the
preparatory fires for the inevitable uh
political long knives that will come out
after they get crushed in the midterms
they know they need a dynamic candidate
based on the crop the republicans have i
would say the one variable to consider
is the trump factor because what biden
has said is i'm the guy to run against
trump should there be a rematch in 2024
and him and his team would may attempt
to try to make that argument i'm not
saying it's the right argument that
would be the only rationale they would
attempt to make do not minimize the
extent to which former obama officials
who are there in that white house don't
want to lose their cat bird seat of
power there as well so i don't think he
goes easily but the clear signs amongst
those who want to win elections are it's
time to turn the page i love the cap
bertsy
imagery that's one of my favorite words
of the day that and earlier today hammer
said he was splendid so i mean i'm
having a pretty good word
i am all right hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now